this is a production of Cornell
University
okay good morning I thought I'd put my
acknowledgment slide first since the end
is I was hard to get to so the numerous
people that were possible that made the
research possible that I'll talk about
in a bit as well as many funding sources
that made this possible and if there's
probably oversights but this is a decent
stab that the people that have
contributed what I wanted to do is first
kind of put things into perspective and
talk a little bit about the flora
culture and horticulture and the
importance that they are in the US and
the New York economy and then talk a bit
more about abiotic stress tolerance and
then kind of okay look at case studies
and abiotic stress tolerance in
floriculture crops which would be a
primary focus of my research program so
if you look at the horticulture industry
in the US you can broadly divide it into
three groups fruits nuts and berries
which in 2007 were worth eighteen point
six billion dollars wholesale farm gate
value second would be nursery greenhouse
in sod so flora culture would very much
fit into this category so this would be
the crops that you can't eat but you can
still enjoy them and then vegetables for
fourteen point seven billions so
collectively about fifty billion dollars
worth of horticultural crops if you
compare that to the hundreds of millions
of acres of corn and soybeans and wheat
that are grown they're valued at seventy
seven point two billion dollars so this
would be a much more intensive type of
Agriculture production the flora culture
industry specifically in the US which
would be comprised primarily of cut
flowers potted plants bedding plants and
propagate of materials cuttings and
seeds and bulbs and things like that
that go into the above crops it's about
a four billion dollar industry a year it
has declined a little bit since the
recession in 2008 so it was higher back
in 2007 and among the the various types
of crops that we grow bedding plants
which would be annuals and perennials
that are grown primarily in the spring
is sold in the spring and then are
supposed to be transplanted into your
scape or transplanted into into hanging
baskets in containers and things like
that they make up about two billion
dollars or about half of the u.s. flora
culture industry and those will be the
crops that are gonna primarily focus on
a little bit with potted plants as well
which would be things like poinsettias
and orchids that were more enjoying
inside our house and then throwing away
once they look ugly if you're like me so
New York State's flora culture industry
has about 600 production operations with
a wholesale value approaching 200
million dollars
we have 568 acres of greenhouses and our
national ranking has varied from about
50 to 8 since I've been in New York and
it sort of just depends on the year and
how well New York growers did and as
that compares to the rest of the country
so if we have six good weekends of sales
in April and May and early June that can
that can really improve the economic
value even the wholesale value of our
industry and to put it into context if
you look at the other agriculture
commodities in New York State the top
four or so are all related to the dairy
industry pretty much so either milk or
our feedstocks to support the milk
production and then apples would be
number five and floriculture would be
number six so the question is why study
abiotic stress tolerance and we'll back
up and take kind of this holistic
worldwide perspective and if you think
about the increasing worldwide scarcity
of resources such as water arable land
and then fossil fuels which we need to
either heat greenhouses or run farm
equipment or bring things to market
fossil fuels are also the inputs for
petrochemicals which are used heavily in
agriculture and horticulture as well so
in addition global climate change means
that we're having these more erratic
temperatures and more erratic water
availability and in general if we have
plants that are more resistant to any of
these stresses whether they be drought
or heat
maybe cold stress if we could grow a
plant in a greenhouse with with less
heat and allow it to be colder this
would improve our situation in terms of
producing more crops using resources
more efficiently and I thought this was
interesting this was from the UN the
predict the projected world population
we're currently at seven billion and
this could go probably following the
kind of medium thought by the UN is that
this would go up to nine billion in
fairly short order and peaking out at
about ten billion or so however if you
look at kind of a worst case scenario
for world population it would be
increasing just as fast over the next
hundred years as it has for the past
hundred years and so besides the
population growing to nine billion by
2040 the UN tells us that by 2030 be on
population growth we're going to have
three billion more middle class
consumers which mean people that can
afford to eat either more calories or
more calories as meat or other other
high-quality foodstuffs so we're going
to need to be able to produce fifty
percent more food and yet with this
we're gonna need 45 percent more energy
to do that and 30 percent more water to
do that and I'm going to be talking
about abiotic stress and the reason I'm
going to do that is I'm not an
entomologist or a pathologist so I don't
work with insect stresses or virus
stresses or disease stresses but
essentially things like salinity drought
heat chilling freezing flooding
nutrients whether they're inadequate or
their their excessive I thought this was
funny this was someone's hanging basket
that they killed because of drought
stress and so they put a couple of
skulls on it to decorate it for
Halloween and so you might ask when do
flora culture crops exhibit abiotic
stress if we're growing them in these
nice perfect greenhouse environments and
I would argue that the plants are
potentially experiencing stress at many
different stages throughout their life
it could be
yes in the production stage in the
greenhouse whether the grower forgets to
irrigate them or doesn't want to
irrigate them as much as they like
whether the group whether the greenhouse
gets excessively hot and in the
summertime when the Sun does come out
greenhouses heat up very quickly that's
called the greenhouse effect by trapping
heat and also there's there's been look
by farmers trying to use minimally
heated or unheated greenhouses simple
structures such as high tunnels for
growing greenhouse crops and that's but
in I've done some research in that area
as well and so if you have plants that
can handle you know chilling stressors
or freezing stresses during production
that would be helpful for them as well
so besides just the greenhouse
production stage then you can look at
the retail stage of the crop so my
daughter and I walked into Walmart last
spring and we saw these nice impatience
hanging baskets here
and I asked my four-year-old daughter
okay what's what's wrong with the plant
on the right and she said daddy does it
need more water and I said yes you got
it but the the truth is about half of
the flora culture products that we sell
are marketed through these big-box
stores and when they get there very
little attention is paid to caring for
them so a large grower that I spoke to
in Michigan said that if he he sells his
plants in two large supermarkets he says
if they don't sell them within three
days at the supermarket they pretty much
go into the dumpster and so despite the
fact that you could theoretically
continue to water this plant to
fertilize this plant and care for it
before it gets purchased by a consumer
and brought to their house it just isn't
happening and so if we could add you
know some days on to the shelf-life of
that plant that would be beneficial okay
and then of course in the landscape or
like in this hanging basket essentially
once the product gets to the consumer if
we can make it last longer and make it
more enjoyable for them we're more
likely to engage the the public in
buying flora culture products so if we
look at why it's important to improve
the abiotic stress tolerance and flora
culture crops you could think of kind of
the short term maybe current grower
mentality and that would be to improve
profitability so if you have plants more
resistant
to stress or these problems you're going
to reduce crop losses or get away with a
higher quality crop even though maybe
old-fashioned petunia variety that from
20 years ago may not have put up with
that kind of stress and may have died
quickly it can allow us to reduce input
such as water fertilizer and energy and
improve consumer success with their
products ultimately I kind of look at it
more as the long-term survival of the
industry and so in light of all of these
declining resources worldwide
floriculture is going to need to compete
against agriculture and if our society
looks at okay we need fruit and in
vegetables and grain crops because we
eat them we may not need flowers so
there may be this perception as flowers
as a luxury item and so if there's
competing resources a luxury item is
going to eventually lose out so what are
your thoughts in the audience here today
our flower is a luxury item there's no
right answer yes or no yeah
okay if if oh right depends where they
are they're in your house or in your
garden others maybe it depends if you're
well fed every day is there no then then
you're not thinking so much about your
caloric intake and then then they're not
so much a luxury item so I would I would
counter some of the arguments with okay
so flowers are a luxury item how about
fresh tomatoes in New York in January
which you know there could be several
months of the year where our ancestors
lived on root vegetables for you know
for years and years and years and so
growing these crops somewhere else or in
a heated greenhouse could be a luxury
item and bananas year-round in the u.s.
grain fed meat and then you could go
even farther and think about you know
what are all of the ways that we spend
our carbon footprint like driving a car
to work every day taking a plane to go
to our annual conferences and things
like that so in the end I think there's
not this black and white area where
flowers should be labeled a luxury item
but it's more of this gray scale of how
does our site how does our society
prioritize how we you know allocate the
resources that we have and I would argue
that you know we all know that flowers
beautify our surroundings like Alex
mentioned you know if they're outdoors
there's there's research that shows that
if you landscape a house properly it can
increase the resale value by as much as
14 percent and you know that we've had
houses sitting on the market for a long
time a well landscaped house apparently
sells six weeks sooner so there's a real
a real economic value associated with
them there if you look at plants in an
indoor environment you know that you can
look at dozens of papers that find
specific benefits such as they reduce
the carbon dioxide in an indoor
environment they reduce the volatile
organic compounds one study found worker
productivity was increased 12%
there were X number of house plants per
square feet of office space and likewise
reduced employee sick days
worked with hospitals fines decreased
length of hospital stay so those are all
very real economic values as well as so
if I were to summarize my research
program over the past five years the
central theme could be a biotic stress
tolerance and then there would be
different aspects of it that I've looked
at and a couple I'm not really gonna
focus on today so fertilizers and
fertilizer use efficiency with either
conventional fertilizers or organic
fertilizers has been a large part of my
research program but we'll save that for
a different discussion as well as I've
collaborated with Chris Wien to look at
growing bedding plants and unheated high
tunnels and you know sort of sorting out
which species and cultivars are more
successful under those conditions and
which ones are not and what are you know
the the length the lengthening of the
crop production time that it might take
and what are the effects of plant
quality but instead we're going to focus
just on these three primary topics and
so we'll start by looking at screening
for cell tolerance and then we'll move
on to look at exogenously rates and then
finally some molecular techniques so
first screening for assault and drought
tolerance and why the focus on drought
and salt stress so a lot of the abiotic
stress tolerance I talked about will be
drought and salt stress but not all of
it you'll see some different stresses so
agriculture accounts for 70% of global
water use an irrigated land is quite
important it represents only about 20%
farmland but it supplies 42 percent of
the world's food so it's you know very
efficient land in terms of production
yields saline soils also represents 7%
of the world land area and so if we're
looking at needing this increasing
amount of arable land or land that we
can access to increase our food supply
by 50% we're going to have to be better
at growing crops either on saline soils
or using saline irrigation water and in
some cases drought and salt stress might
be thought of as having similar effects
on the
plant some of the effects would be
osmotic effects or you know high salt
concentration in the in the soil makes
it difficult for roots to extract enough
water to meet the needs of the top part
of the plant and so that can be thought
of as a physiological drought so wilting
shorter plants reduce leaf surface area
and then the responses of the plants are
just a model closure or an increase in
reactive oxygen species and the
depending on the type of salt that
you're looking at certainly there can be
more salt specific effects so that could
be seen you know like the cell damage
here which could be due to excess
accumulation of sodium and chloride
leading to cell wall disruption and
previous to that enzyme disruption so on
so the first person in my lab was
Gonzalo Villa RINO and he started as a
master student now he's a PhD student
his first project with me was to screen
14 of the most popular bedding plants
for salt tolerance so I wanted to see
okay of the of the plants that were that
were growing how problematic is it and
then using this develop some practical
guidelines for greenhouse growers so in
the end Gonzalez selected 14 species the
ones highlighted in red could be thought
of as among the kind of top ten flora
culture crops and there's a couple that
aren't in the top ten that we didn't
have and essentially had seedlings that
we started we transplanted them and grew
them on for five weeks exposing them to
sodium chloride in the irrigation water
and that ranged from zero up to eighty
millimolar and then you could look at
their growth in terms of relative dry
weight for example so that would be if
the looking at the dry weight of a zero
millimolar plant and then what is the
you know corresponding percent reduction
in relative dry weight and if you do
that then you can look at all of the
plants together and see which ones are
the most tolerant to to this particular
cell stress and which ones are the most
sensitive if you don't do this type of
equilibration then you're looking at
okay maybe petunias are a much larger
plant to start with than pansy and so
it's difficult to look at you in the
shape of the curve and how sensitive
they are so what we found is yes Peter
so every watering did so it was a pretty
excessive that's right uh-huh
we did take weekly pour through leachate
values to look at what was the pH and
what was the electrical conductivity
inside of the root zone and what we
found is that after a couple of weeks
we've got a pretty stable EC in the root
zone we did that because we applied a
bit excess irrigation water so every
time we wanted we leached a little bit
of water and it also leaked showed a bit
of soluble salts as well mm-hmm so
looking at just just a few of the plants
so we found Snapdragon and Petunia were
among the most tolerant that adding this
eighty millimolar sodium chloride after
five weeks they were about half the size
of control plants whereas there were
some plants like pansy which were all
dead at the end of the five week period
so snapdragons would be representative
of the the tolerant group and they they
produce mannitol or a carbohydrate that
can act as an asthma protectant pansies
are very sensitive
salvia where were quite sensitive and
begonia you know kind of intermediate in
their sensitivity and tolerance so in
the end we came up with this grouping
where the most tolerant species we said
had their dry weight reduced by 50 to 70
percent with 80 millimolar sodium
chloride and these are somewhat
artificial but you know we looked at the
14 species and were there kind of some
obvious groups that came out of it
somewhat tolerant plants moderately
sensitive and then the extremely
sensitive plants were zinnia and pansy
which had a hundred percent mortality at
high salts I had the opportunity now now
peas are not a floriculture crop I guess
sweet peas are a floriculture crop but I
had a visiting scientist from Pakistan
last year and and
and prior to that I had met him
virtually and had gotten to serve as a
member of his graduate committee he has
been looking at the effect of salt
stress on Peas and he initially did
screening studies to look at which pea
genotypes were more tolerant and what
were some of the underlying reasons for
that and then he went on to look at some
exogenous
of of compounds to improve that
tolerance and I'll talk about that in a
minute as well so P is apparently an
important crop in Pakistan it's an
important for the food of their culture
Pakistan as well as 11th in the world in
pea production producing 84 thousand
tons on 12,000 hectares and they also
have problems with salt apparently 20%
of their arable land is is affected by
salt and so the work that he did is
initially screening these 30 P genotypes
to sodium chloride in the irrigation
water and that was added to achieve
thresholds of zero two point five five
or seven point five Desa Siemens per
meter so they'll be measured with the
electrical conductivity meter and
eventually from those 30 he chose two
that were quite solid quite salt
tolerant and representative of that
group and two that were quite sensitive
and representative of that group and
then he further went on to look at some
of their the morphology and physiology
associated with their resistance and
their tolerance and just to highlight a
couple of his interesting findings so we
have two cultivars there ambassador and
PF 400 which were salt sensitive and
then we have two cultivars climax and
Sam arena's art which were tolerant and
looking at plant dry weight in response
to increasing salinity and he found that
the most tolerant cultivars showed very
little decrease whereas there was this
you know quite linear quite quite strong
decrease in plant dry weight for the
sensitive cultivars a very similar
pattern was found as well for seed
weight and for yield of the plant
so I'm not going to show those graphs
but essentially you know just by
selecting from existing cultivars you
could you could choose plants that are
more able to be used on these saline
soils this is interesting this is the
graphs can be difficult to read but it's
sodium content in the roots on the left
side and the leaves on the right side
and what he found is that the two most
tolerant cultivars actually accumulated
a lot of sodium in their roots but that
did not get translocated to their leaves
so in the end the the sensitive
cultivars accumulated a lot of sodium in
their leaves so it could be that you
know sort of trapped or held by the
roots or just not you know they had
selectivity in their translocation and
did not translocate that to their leaves
then suite of antioxidant enzymes was
looked at and we talked about you know
with the salt or increasing salt and
drought stress you would expect the
plant to respond by enhancing its
antioxidant enzyme content and
expression and what we found is that the
sensitive cultivars really did not do
that to a very large degree so there
would be the the dark blue bar and the
red bar you know really minor kind of
increments in their antioxidant enzyme
expression whereas the more tolerant
cultivars that seems to be a decently
large mechanism involved in their
tolerance they were able to almost
double the antioxidant enzymes and this
is superoxide dismutase but that is
representative of several over the other
of the enzymes that he looked at another
mechanism for salt tolerance can be we
talked about Ozma protectants and so
glycine but beta n was one of the
osmolytes that was looked at and that
was a quite similar story as the
antioxidant enzymes where it really did
not increase to much of a degree for the
sensitive plants but the tolerant plants
exposed to high salts
you know doubled the amount of osmolytes
that they had
so the conclusion from that work was
that salt stress significantly reduced
these these attributes that we looked at
growth in yield and so on but the the
salt tolerance potential of P genotypes
types is highly linked with a couple of
these traits and that was as mole lights
and antioxidant enzymes as well as the
restricted movement of sodium chloride
from the roots to the leaves and so if
you were selecting you know if you were
going back to screen you know 30
genotypes 100 genotypes of peas and
looking at which ones were tolerant to
salt these were these will probably be
good characteristics to look at as
indicators for result are tolerant
genotypes so with that I want to look at
exogenous
that can improve tolerance and so you
could think about okay is there
something that I can spray on my plant
or apply to my plant that can make it
withstand this distress better and so my
colleague in Pakistan has looked at
briceño steroids and I'll talk about
them first
they're from the steroid class of
hormones and they apparently improve
membrane stability and osmotic
adjustment and also have effects you
know and gene signaling and enhancing
the plant defense system a second
project I'll talk about was with seaweed
or kelp extract a commercial product
called stem flex and it does have high
concentration of beta ins which are
acting as osmolytes
but it really contains hundreds of
compounds and we're just beginning to
understand which of those hundreds of
compounds are important in the stress
tolerance benefits of seaweed and then
last a silicon which is considered
beneficial nutrient but not an essential
nutrient and it apparently mediates
systemic resistance by the plant does
have an effect on antioxidant enzyme
expression and membrane stability so
we'll delve into those a little bit more
so a bit more with with Adnan's work and
and he he's gotten 50 pages written on
this in his PhD thesis but to summarize
this simply one experiment that he do
with this briceño steroid was soaked
seeds with a briceño steroid were not
soaked in with that person a steroid
prior to assault stress and he did that
as a seed soaking treatment as well and
he used 1 millimolar sodium chloride and
10 millimolar sodium chloride whereas
the type of person a steroid that he
used was applied at 10 micromolar and if
you look at the the plant dry weight and
I don't have significant virus in here
to make things brief but essentially so
if you if you soaked the seeds in salt
that reduce their dry weight if you
soaked them in the briceño steroid first
and then with with salts you could
enhance the dry weight even above the
control dry weight and he's also got
treatments where he just used the the
briceño steroid and their their dry
weight was even greater than within
these plants and he looked at several
different parameters that were
associated with that and he found that
the Briceno steroids did improve the
activity of the production of
antioxidant enzymes increased
photosynthetic parameters and so on so
this could be a you know potentially
useful tool and mitigating that salt
stress I had a couple Chinese scientists
that looked with this commercial extract
of kelp and looking at whether this
alleviated salt stress in petunia
verbena tomato and Snapdragon and
essentially what we did is we grew these
seedlings we transplanted them and then
kind of similar to Gonzalez work we gave
them salt continuously in the irrigation
water and that was 40 millimolar salt so
what we have noted here is that we have
the treatments are without sodium
fluoride without sodium chloride and
then those are - dimplex or the kelp
extractor + dimplex which is that kelp
extract and then we have plus 40
millimolar sodium chloride but without
the kelp extra
Plus sodium chloride and with that kelp
extract and in particular we see that we
saw this trend for all four species but
with Virginia and verbena it was
significant for all of the treatments is
that if we have control plants so not
exposed to salt so that would be like
the blue bar on the left if we then
expose them to weakly drenches of stem
flecks which was applied at five
milliliters per liter of this commercial
preparation we got a significant
increase in the dry weight of the plant
and this could relate to you know the
cytokinins potentially in it or other
compounds then if we if we take a plant
that that is exposed to 40 millimeters
odium chloride like this petunia and the
green bar you see that its growth is
much reduced compared to plants that
didn't get salt and if we add this this
dimplex this kelp extract we saw a
significant increase in its dry weight
so not enough you know to get it
anywhere back close to the control dry
weight this was a pretty severe salt
stress though so that would that we saw
with petunia and verbena one of the
things that we looked at was a response
for some of the photosynthetic
parameters and if you look at just net
photosynthetic rate what we found and I
apologize for the changes in color but
the the setup is very similar is that
could plants that were not treated with
salt but received this kelp extract had
a greatly increased photosynthetic rate
however when we looked at plas that had
been treated with salt and then we
looked at their photosynthetic rate we
did not see any significant differences
between them and it could be at that
point Nina the cells were so impaired
that there was not this particular
improvement of photosynthesis but quite
interesting that even control plants you
know not treated with salt but got this
kelp extract had improved photosynthetic
rate
we've also started some trials where
we've grown these plants in a greenhouse
with weekly drenches of kelp extract and
then we bring them to kind of a
simulated retail environment so just
indoors water them once and then we let
them we let them wilt as they will and
we find that so this is a tomato five
days with no water and our control plant
if you can see looks you know somewhat
more wilted than our kelp extract
treated plant and we're we're repeating
that research right now with a new
visiting Chinese scientist we're gonna
look at that in petunia and tomato so
some of you have heard me speak before
in silicon the use of silicon is a
potentially beneficial nutrient has has
been a topic of interest for some years
now in my lab and silicon is naturally
found in soils plants absorb silicon as
silicic acid which is SiO 8 for or zero
for H four so a single unit of silicon
surrounded by four oxygens and four
hydrogen's and the people that have
looked at okay what elements are
necessary for a plant to complete its
life cycle as far as they've been able
to exclude silicon out of say hydroponic
solutions and look at it they've never
been able to prove the silicon was
absolutely needed for higher plants to
complete their life cycle but we find
that there's a lot of reports rice was a
good example that rice accumulates
something like five to ten percent of
its dry weight is silicon so that's even
more than nitrogen which is the the
essential nutrient that it takes in the
greatest quantity that if you've farmed
rice in the same field for several
decades the soil can become depleted of
the silicon and then they started seeing
plants that were more prone to getting
diseases and if they supplemented that
soil back with silicon either like a
potassium silicate or calcium silicate
or just by returning say say rice hulls
back to this
that they would see this beneficial
response to disease tolerance and
there's this growing body of research
that that the same is true with various
abiotic stresses as well so with flora
culture crops were typically growing
them in a potting mix that doesn't have
soil so we don't expect a lot of silicon
to be there it's peat and perlite and
some added nutrients what we found when
we've looked at the soil substrates that
we've used that they have about 0.08
millimolar silicon in them the tap water
at Cornell has a little bit of silicon
as an impurity in SF point O three
millimolar silicon and fertilizers might
have a little bit of impurity in it so
we wonder okay is that enough silicon
impurity that if we add more silicon
it's not going to have any effect on the
plant or is the opposite true is it
beneficial to add this the Supplemental
silicon so what we did is we grew 21
floriculture species we gave them 10
weekly drenches of either zero or four
millimolar silicon from potassium
silicate then we looked at leaf tissue
silicon and this this can't be hard to
look at this is the 21 species that we
looked at and we found that their leaf
silicon content varied from petunia on
the left side when it was unamended with
potassium silicate had a concentration
of about 200 parts per million when we
amended it with silicon that that could
go up to 500 parts per million all the
way up to plants like verbena our jar
anthem um and Terranea which had up to
about 4,000 4,500 parts per million
silicon and so here the dark bars refer
to plants that were unamended with
silicon and the open bars are plants
that were amended with silicon so you'll
see example especially some of the
silicon accumulating plants that are
here on the right side so when we did
amend them with silicon we see fairly
dramatic increases in the leaf tissue
levels and then there's a broad group of
plants down here that accumulate fairly
low levels of silicon and so like this
tuberous begonia if we add silicon to
the potassium silicon to the soil there
was no further enhancement of
of leaf tissue silicon so we looked at
which plant showed a significant
increase in their leaf silicon content
once we added it and so the interesting
that petunia which had such low levels
of silicon whether it was amended or not
but if we did amend it it absorbed
something like 130 percent more silicon
than the unamended soils so this was
quite interesting we measured several
morphological parameters so simple
things like just flower diameter height
of the plant stem diameter dry weight
fresh weight and so on and essentially
found some very subtle differences
nothing hugely dramatic with silicon in
some cases there were statistically
significant differences where say flower
diameter was maybe 5 percent wider where
we had silicon something like that we
also found that cultivars within a
species can vary in their silicon
accumulating ability so we found like
geraniums for example one cultivar that
that accumulated more silicon where we
added it and another that did not and
then in the end what we found is that in
the absence of stresses silicon did not
really have a dramatic effect on plant
growth and about that time there was
this growing body of research that
indeed most of the benefits of silicon
are when you have some external stress
whether that be biotic or abiotic so a
postdoc that I had a few years ago
looked at the role of silicon in
poinsettia post-harvest performance and
poinsettias the second largest potted
crop in the US which was recently
overtaken by Phalaenopsis orchids or
just orchids in general a couple years
ago and one of the things that he did
which I'm not going to really show you
is that he grew plants in the greenhouse
with different amounts of irrigation
water so a hundred percent of their
needs eighty percent of their needs or
sixty percent of their needs and so of
course if you grow a plant with less
water then it's taking up you end up
with a smaller plant and one of the
things that he found is that adding
silicon
and as weekly drenches into these
treatments is that this reduction in say
leaf surface area Brack surface area
when the plant was only given 60% but
water needs is that we saw some recovery
in the Brack surface area and some
recovery of the leaf surface area when
we added silicon the other thing that we
did is we took these plants into again a
simulated retail environment so that
post harvest environment watered them
once and then didn't water them again
and look at how long it took them to
Wilk and we saw that the especially for
plants that received a hundred percent
of their irrigation needs that if we
added silicon it took them longer to
wilt and that's reflected here we
measured leaf angle so a larger leaf
angle means a you know more wilted leaf
a leaf closer to 90 degrees would be a
completely wilted leaf and so
interesting that of the of the treatment
so plus and minus silicon and 60 80 or
100 percent of their irrigation needs
the plants that had the lowest leaf
angle where the silicon treated plants
and the ones that had wilted the most
was especially the silicon treated plant
that had gotten 100 percent or not
silicon with a hundred percent of its
water needs we left the plants wilt and
then weary watered them and we found
there was some qualitative benefit at
least to having silicon for wilt to
recovery
my current postdoc Mikkel Moy al has
looked more at silicon effects in
petunia and a lot of the work I'm going
to talk about for the rest of the time
it relates to petunia and we like
petunia because it's the largest bedding
plant for wholesale value in the US has
also been a genetic model for flora
culture species for some 30 years now a
part of that has become because it's
relatively easy to transform so you can
get transgenic plants and look at the
effects of genes it's decently easy to
handle in tissue culture
and so we found some work that Gonzalo
did in hydroponics just like work that
he did in soil found reductions in
petunia growth with increasing sodium
chloride salinity so we wanted to know
if silicon would improve petunia salt
tolerance and so Mikkel did treatments
with silicon at zero to where four
millimolar supplied his weekly drenches
evaluated the plants after seven weeks
and they received a salt stress all
along of zero up to eighty millimolar
sodium chloride what she found is that
the primary effects on the plants were
the salinity effect so this this table
doesn't include silicon but you know
something like the chute dry weight
decreasing from 37 to 13 grams sodium
chloride increased and very little kind
of silicon interaction with that when
she looked a little deeper than we could
see kind of some very subtle indications
that silicon was having benefits to the
plant myself we looked at leaf area we
have plants that receive zero two or
four millimolar silicon and then the
blue bars would be zero millimolar
sodium chloride up to purple which would
be eighty millimolar sodium chloride and
so we found in terms of statistical
significance if we didn't have silicon
but we have that eighty millimolar
sodium chloride we saw a reduction in
leaf surface area if we had silicon
either a two or four millimolar that
statistical significance goes away so
there was a pattern of reduction but it
wasn't large enough to be statistically
significant in our X experiment we
measured chlorophyll index and the lower
leaves were interesting with the lower
leaves we saw a reduction in chlorophyll
index when we didn't have silicon at
eighty millimolar sodium chloride but if
you look at the two and four millimolar
sodium chloride treatments we did not
see a significant reduction at all so
apparently helped
preserve the integrity of chlorophyll
potentially membrane integrity in the
plant
Mikell wanted to know if this will carry
on through to some of the photosynthetic
parameters and so she looked at these
are plants treated with AD millimolar
sodium chloride and then they have
silicon supplemented at zero to a four
millimolar and what she found is a
pattern of increased net photosynthesis
where we had silicon however not
statistically significant with
transpiration or the rate of water loss
out of the leaves we saw a significant
we saw a reduction but not significant
but when she multiplied the two to get
predicted water use efficiency that is
the you know the net co2 that's fixed
per unit of water that's used when you
combine the two we do get this
statistically significant trend that we
have improved water use efficiency and
so that's very much in line with the
previous work that we had with like the
drought tolerance in the coins Etienne
mikkel has also exposed petunia to heat
stress and heat stress we see in the
greenhouse we definitely see in the
landscape especially in the southern
half of the US she initially exposed
petunia to 35 degrees Celsius or 40
degrees Celsius continuously for either
24 hours 72 hours and then after 72
hours pulling it out and looked at
recovery and what we see is we have wilt
index here on the y axis and then we
have heat exposure and then the recovery
period and we find that plants that the
silicon treated plants after one day and
then significant after 72 hours and
significant in the recovery period had
significantly less wilt than their
control counterparts and with 35 degrees
Celsius we saw that trend a 72 degrees
but our 72 hours but in the end was not
a significant trend
the time we got to recovery and the
picture here the left would be the
silicon treated the plants 40 degrees
Celsius for three days and the right
would be the plants that did not get
silicon she followed that up a little
bit more so with with 40 degrees Celsius
planets she measured their leaf
temperature prior to their stress and
then 24 and 72 hours into the stress and
she found a significant reduction in
leaf temperature so maybe that relates
to she walked she watered the plants
well throughout the the period but maybe
they have some improved cooling capacity
with the silicon and chlorophyll
fluorescence or FB over FM a measure of
efficiency of the photosynthetic
apparatus we have plants on the Left
those three different colored bars were
controlled two and four millimolar
silicon before they got 40 degrees
Celsius stress and then after two days
of that stress what we found is that the
plants that didn't have silicon the
controls there their efficiency was
quite reduced where reductions were not
so severe when they had two or four
millimolar silicon during the plant
production phase okay so we can use you
know existing compounds whether they're
beneficial nutrients or kelp extract or
so on and improve stress tolerance I
wanted to touch on a moment molecular
techniques to improve tolerance and the
work that McKell is currently doing is
in rice they know the two carrier genes
and their roots that are responsible for
active silicon uptake and so far those
genes have mostly been found in Graham
Anisha species there's one case of a
dicot where they found silicon uptake
carrier and that's in cucurbit which is
about 1% by dry weight by comparison
you know rice was 5 or 10 percent
silicon by dry weight petunias about
point zero two point zero five percent
by dry
wait and so what mikelis done has cloned
these rice silicon transporters and
we've generated transgenic petunia lines
with transporter 1 or LSI 1 and the
transporter 2 LSI 2 and I'll talk in a
minute about work that she's doing
screening I'll let you know if you if a
plant just has over expressed LSI 1 or
just has over expressed LSI 2 if there's
a particular stress benefit the other
thing that she's doing is now working on
crosses of these plants to obtain a
homozygous line that has single trans
gene copies of both of them so it can
look at okay if you have the combination
of the two carriers together does that
give you a further enhancement and okay
so essentially mcelder qPCR found that
she had about a dozen lines each for LSI
1 and LSI 2 of plants that were enhanced
in their relative expression and the
bars are kind of misleading so even lick
with LSI 1 in this top graph here we
have plants that have you know 7 times
the expression of actin all the way up
to plants that have I don't know 9,000
20,000 times the the expression as a
housekeeping gene and a similar story
for LSI to so anyways she was successful
in obtaining a range of transgenic lines
that varied in their expression levels
for those LSI one overexpressed plants
we grew them in a greenhouse with
supplemental either point 0.5 or 2
millimolar silicon and an interesting
thing is some of the highly expressing
lines at 2 millimolar silicon we could
see a bit of phyto toxicity you see that
leaf in the lower right and yet if we
look at the the the silicon content in
the tissue we don't see a particular
especially a 2 millimolar silicon we
don't see a significant difference in
the silicon content of those leaves as
compared to a wild-type plant so
something may be related to the we use
35 s as that promoter for the gene not a
specific promoter looking at the silicon
content we did see that for our
transgenic plants with no silicon
amended at all
they statistically had the same silicon
content levels as as a wild-type plant
with 0.5 millimolar silicon and then a
transgenic plants with 0.5 millimolar
silicon statistically had the same
amount of silicon in them as a wild-type
plant with 2 millimolar silicon so you
know one potential benefit of these
plants is they could be better posed to
scavenge the the silicon that is
existing in the soil and not having to
apply eggs on a silicon to obtain the
same benefit and she did she did
screened five of the lines to heat
stress and she found that there was
significant reduction in wilt index for
some of the lines and she's just started
now to look at some of the explanations
for that and she has shown for example a
lower leaf temperature again for the
transgenic lines even at 0.5 millimolar
silicon worse for wild type plants it
took at least two millimolar silicon to
see those benefits I just wanted to
point out mikelis collaborating with dr.
andre kessler in the ecology and
evolutionary biology department
McKell has a background in analyzing
volatile and plants and manipulating
that process and they're looking at
cucumber there they're feeding it three
different types or of herbivores or
they're giving a three different types
of herbivores and with it with us
silicon and then looking at at you know
a river ii or damage to the leaf as well
as some of the fingerprint of the
volatile compounds that are given off
and that's very much in its preliminary
stages and we wanted to mention my grad
student Gonzalo is working on my PhD
with me and one of the projects that
he's looking at it's one of the chapters
in his PhD is exploiting the treeless
pathway to improve salt and drought
tolerance of the two
yeah so this this is a pathway that's
previously been used but in the past so
we have we have some intermediates to
tree hello switch is a sugar and two of
the potential bottlenecks the enzymes
that mediate those would be TPS and TPP
in the past people have looked at
overexpressing TPS implants and they
found and improve salt tolerance and
drought tolerance and what we want to do
is look at okay is the combination of
both required or can we get a more
efficient response if they're both
required or if we add them both together
and using petunia as our model species
you know the petunia genome hasn't been
sequenced yet but using tomato as a
reference genome Gazala was able to
clone TPS at TPP successfully from
petunia and sequence of them and
confirmed their function in a yeast
system so that adds a bit to the our
knowledge on petunia genes and so he's
added those into the NCBI database so
ultimately we're looking at does the
expression of TPS and TPP improve salt
and drug tolerance do the either of the
genes alone work or combined are they
more efficient as well as there's this
growing body of evidence that the total
amount of trehalose that is accumulated
isn't so important that it's acting more
as a signaling molecule as opposed to an
imprimatur plants a large amount of
trealose can accumulate and there it's
acting as an osmotic tint so we'd like
to sort out okay our benefits related to
more signaling or to that Osmo
protection
all right so with that I would just
conclude by saying you know tackling
these world problems resource shortages
is going to take you know all of our
combined efforts to do that and
essentially this integrated approach of
but it's room for people to look at
production practices that you use these
resources efficiently we've talked about
screening and other people of during
breeding the plants that tolerate stress
exogenous compounds that we can use to
enhance stress tolerance and then
ultimately you know they're these
molecular approaches where are rewarding
as well so thank you for your attention
and I'll ask if there's any questions
yeah that's interesting and I had
thought one of my hypotheses was okay
maybe for the silicon benefit with with
that heat stress or dress dress or cell
stress something like that maybe it
allows the the plant to use water more
efficiently in that that does seem to be
the case but yet there's some underlying
reason so you know there's less
transpiration from the leaf surface
you'd think there'd be less of a loss of
that heat energy so it seems like
there's some other mechanism that's
taking place and I don't have a great
hypothesis for that I know that there
was actually a sort of a biophysicist
looking at the problem and they found if
there were decent particular deposits of
silicon that they acted as kind of this
heat sink of the leaf and so in that
case it was very much a physical kind of
benefit of these particular deposits in
the leaf but that I haven't looked at
that at all for any of the species that
I've looked at with silicon so that's
interesting the question is could some
of the silicon benefits be reflectance
yeah I think I would certainly follow
through with that and I'm not familiar
with literature looking at that for
plants that for Grandma nauseous plants
that accumulate a lot of silicon one of
the benefits that they're talking about
is a physical benefit of having a more
upright plant that can sometimes
intercept more light for photosynthesis
but that would be you know that's a
different kind of phenomenon but that
just that reflectance itself will be
interesting to pursue mm-hmm
the question is do the plants look
different for them from what I can tell
from from wild type plants that I've
treated with silicon it's very hard I
cannot really discern differences with
poinsettias I could find slightly
thicker stems when they were treated
with silicon it was interesting for me
for mikkel one of the transgenic lines
that she had that was that was highly
expressing LSI one we did see a more
erect kind of petunia so it was the the
wild-type is more of the sprawling kind
of petunia form and one of the
transgenic lines was decently more erect
which I would say had a firmer stem in a
wider stem so in that case there was at
least in this transgenic case a a
morphological difference and I would say
probably rice starved of silicon
compared to rice given plenty of silicon
you would see those type of differences
and I was say the the reason we jumped
to trehalose was we knew it had worked
in the past in a rabid abscess I was
interested in say okay I'm a flora
culturist but demonstrating that we can
use molecular biology techniques in a
flora culture crop but then there are
some interesting questions related to
the tree hollows pathway that aren't
answered even in a rabid abscess so
that's something that we could
potentially contribute to the literature
one of Gonzalez chapters is going to be
Illumina high-throughput sequencing of
petunias with and without self stress
for varying lengths of time and so that
would be very much like what you're
talking about where
looking at the existing body and seeing
which genes are highly involved in say
cell tolerance with us our so yeah we'll
get there Peter yeah and so in that
sense realizing that the toolkit that we
have with a rabid abscess with with
knockouts that exist and you know our
genome that has been fully sequenced and
so on will help us move forward to
answer those questions more directly
right oh that's a great question because
although when I talk about that a lot
whether transgenic flora culture crops
might be more accepted by the public
than transgenic food crops and I don't
know the answer to that I was talking
with
I was at a conference in the Netherlands
a couple weeks ago and some colleagues
there were saying that the public there
is quite resistant to GMOs and what
other whatever whether they eat it or
not yet in Japan we have the first case
of a transgenic flower so called blue
rose that that is now licensed there on
the market and that is apparently
available in the US now although I've
never seen them and ultimately you know
if you want to get a transgenic crop
you're gonna have to spend something
what was that several hundred million
dollars Peter would have answers to that
you know to go through the the hoops of
showing this is a safe plant to use in
it's a given case and that the as so on
is so that those obstacles if you look
at flora culture crops compared to like
corn you know petunia which is the the
largest value bedding plant is worth 200
million dollars a year so no one's going
to spend a hundred million dollars in
hoops in trying to get a transgenic
petunia yeah at least we don't have to
do feeding trials but you know we'd
still have to do like pollinator trials
and then okay are there petunias in the
landscape that the gene could spread to
and do you need male sterility things
like that so ultimately it's a ways off
I think if we ever get to a more
streamline procedure where they said
okay if you're a flora culture crop not
a food crop you only have to pass
through these hurdles and made that more
efficient
I think I think we could get there
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu